so there I was standing there in the
church
for the first time in my life I realized
I totally and utterly loved one person
[Music]
it wasn't
and it was it wasn't the person standing
next to me in the in lavell
[Music]
there was the present standing opposite
me in the rain is it still raining hello
hello hi what's your name my name is
Anita Anita lovely and where do you live
in Egypt
I live in Manchester and it's my
birthday today what does he want a prize
Gold warden you know watching my
daughter sing jingle bells over and over
again okay and then the headline would
be not to be bored by child
dueling men Campos my second power what
are you joy
[Applause]
[Music]
you're about to advertise Churchill's
car insurance I'm gonna put into water
my medicine I cough the water yes
now I'm gonna come across this way you
don't come to like your ear then you
just turn hey it looks like I can nail
you already ready on three one two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're like
I still going
that's what I've got to fix our wind
song
I know you gotta keep you know keep that
going for a few seconds ago this was
genius because it's got a headband yes
so no one will ever know it's a wig you
know suits you know I don't like a
chalice what are you telling me you've
never met have you never see something
have you never met a Spice Girl I'm wait
hold on
have you never met a Spice Girl riding
the flash okay now as you know
[Music]
it's very rare it's very rare for more
than one Spice Girl to appear together
for any reason at all so they're not
here
[Applause]
hello hello is that Jenson Button Graham
Norton and a very disappointed audience
[Applause]
okay we want the excuse and it better be
good
well I was out on my push bike nice
weather and this beat comes along and
stings me on the bridge of my nose which
is obviously a big shock initially
massive pain and what have you
yes and suddenly I got massive headache
and I look like a balloon but I don't
think you can go wrong with a nice place
of hand shredded ask me everyone's
favorite towards some more
just another handful that savvy you know
[Laughter]
this is a special brunch for the weekend
I might have the fresh salad followed by
a variety of opinions you still go
clubbing do soak up a rock you have
never ever been to a club in my life you
like a rope oh do I yes never been to a
nightclub yes you have
I didn't you in hand
[Applause]
solutely to this I
through the back door
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]